[Music]
this Tuesday night the feds on the home
front their long awaited solutions to
end the housing Supply crisis our goal
is to help Canadians through un
incredibly challenging time when the
funds will be freed up plus what this
means for renters and Airbnb owners the
growing optimism about a Gaza hostage
deal what's in it and how long the
fighting could stop
no ceasefire in Gaza means more
suffering the evacuation of hospitals
the important point is where to and the
new medical facilities being built plus
things that just didn't make any sense
the clues that led to a big bust of
counterfeit
coins global national with Donna Fen
reporting tonight Maron
Nasser good evening we begin with
breaking news out of the Middle East and
from from the Israeli Prime Minister's
office Israel's cabinet has reportedly
just voted to approve a deal that will
see the release of several Hamas held
hostages in exchange for a pause in the
fighting in Gaza and the release of
Palestinian Prisoners the deal was
brokered by the US and qar according to
the Israeli Prime Minister's office 50
hostages women and children will be
released over four days during which
there will be a halt in the fighting but
despite this deal Benjamin Netanyahu
Israel's prime minister adamantly said
earlier today that Israel is prepared to
resume its campaign in Gaza until all of
its goals are reached and that includes
the total elimination of Hamas and the
recovery of more than 200 hostages that
the group is believed to be holding Mike
Armstrong now on the details behind this
agreement and how it's being
received they have gathered in Tel Aviv
in a park that's come to be known as
hostages Plaza
families and friends some hanging on
every bit of news about a potential deal
others too nervous to follow anything
chamelia is's 13-year-old granddaughter
is believed to be held by
Hamas she says she's just waiting for a
call to say G is free then she'll know
it's over we cannot comment on the
details of the phrase coming from every
side echoed again this evening by the
qari government is that a deal is close
qar has been acting as a mediator
Hamas leadership addressed the media in
Lebanon Tuesday calling this a decisive
moment but adding they've thought they
had a deal before and Israel backed out
well this is the first time a proposed
deal has gotten this far Benjamin
Netanyahu is taking the proposed
agreement to the government as prime
minister he doesn't have the power to
sign off on it himself the deal would
require Israel to hand over 150 women
and teenagers it has detained that's
something Netanyahu can't do alone in
return Hamas would hand over 50 hostages
women and children a ratio of 3:1 now
the other parts of the deal both sides
would pause fighting for a short time
four or 5 days and more Aid would be
allowed into
Gaza now the fighting won't stop
immediately under Israeli law there'll
be a 24-hour window for someone to
appeal the approval of the deal to the
Supreme Court they could still be
quashed the prime minister is also
saying once a pause is over the fighting
will pick up again in full force now
there is one possible exception Hamas is
believed to be holding about 240
hostages if it decides it's willing to
hand over more than just that first 50
Israeli officials say they're open to
expanding the pause
Farah Mike Armstrong in Jerusalem thank
you for that Mike Palestinian Health
officials under Hamas control in Gaza
now say they have lost the ability to
count the Dead the near collapse at the
health system and the difficulty
retrieving bodies has made it all but
impossible to tract at last count which
again cannot be verified more than
11,000 Palestinian people are believed
to have been killed more than 4,500 of
them are children and more bombings hit
communities in gaza's North and South
today as Redmond Shannon reports as
residents wait for the fighting to stop
the suffering goes on and a warning some
of the content here is
disturbing no pause in the suffering
only more chaos and
grief so much so that gazan officials
told the Associated Press they can no
longer reliably count the
dead as well as its ground operation
Israeli air strikes are still killing
people in the north and south of the
Strip This the aftermath at gaza's
largest refugee camp in the North
Doctors Without Borders and the red
cresant say that that attack included a
strike on a maternity hospital that
killed three doctors and the World
Health Organization says its staff
member dimma alhaj and her family were
killed in Gaza too reportedly while
Sheltering in a
house the who says it's working to
evacuate three hospitals in the besieged
north but again the important point is
where to there's no safe space there are
the only places they can go to right now
are non-specialized hosp hospitals in
the
South these patients arrived South to an
already overwhelmed Hospital in canun we
don't have enough supplies we don't have
enough
ventilators uh the hospital condition is
very Miser work is underway building two
Jordanian donated field hospitals in
canun one for trauma patients a second
for premature babies The Who estimates
that every day another 20 newborns need
Specialist Care in
Gaza this video from the red cresant
shows more newborns being brought to
Egypt on Tuesday but this boy is staying
behind Dr Muhammad Al Anar says no one
knows where the baby's parents or family
are so for now at least Medics will do
their best for him here a child whose
future is as uncertain as that of Gaza
Redmond Chann Global News
London and the fighting has claimed the
lives of two more journalists a Beirut
TV station Al mayadin says a
correspondent a cameraman and a civilian
who was with them were killed by an
Israeli air strike in southern Lebanon a
little later on of the newscast we're
going to explain the potential Ripple
effects of the deal for the
us back here in Canada the federal
government has updated its spending
plans the update suggests Canada will
avoid a recession
but there is no immediate growth on the
horizon it does outline new guard rails
to demonstrate fiscal restraint but
there is one clear Focus for the liberal
government this is about housing it is
about Supply Supply
Supply the update outlines new fiscal
measures designed to boost the housing
Supply but much of the spending is tied
to policies and programs that are
already in place our chief political
correspondent David Akin's gone through
the report and he joins us now from
Ottawa with more details David yeah far
this is the fall economic statement that
Christ Freeland tabled in the House of
Commons 131 Pages full of tables and
charts about the government's fiscal
picture but as you heard the minister
say there's really only one theme Here
build more homes
faster we are unlocking billions of
dollars in new financing money that will
go towards supporting the construction
of new homes for Canadians and sure
enough this fiscal state statement does
commit Ottawa to putting another $16
billion into a pot to build more homes
but that new money will not be available
for 2 years after the next election
which means the government is relying on
an existing $38 billion pot it created
in 2017 and that begs the question how
the government is helping end a housing
Supply crisis now our government really
understands that housing is an urgent
concern of Canadians federal government
may have the resources but the provinces
of the power and the municipalities have
the problem so really the three or of
government actually have to work
together to increase Supply the
government is going to do something else
right away introduced steep Financial
disincentives for those operating
short-term rentals in certain markets
the so-called Airbnb business in the
hopes owners of those units will move
them into the long-term rental market
and for those already paying a mortgage
worried about being swamped by higher
interest rates the government is
announcing a Canadian mortgage Charter
something it says will give homeowners a
little more leverage when renegotiating
with their lender but the charter is not
binding on lenders it is only voluntary
our goal is to help Canadians through an
incredibly challenging Time by making
sure Canadians have the support they
need to afford their mortgages and keep
their homes when renewing at a time of
higher interest rates now finally ever
since the trudo government was elected
in 2015 it has only once shown a path
back to a balanced budget and that was
in fact in last year's fall economic
statement this year that path back to a
balanced budget is obscured by deficits
albeit relatively small ones as far as
the eye can see no balanced budget far
something that will be criticized by the
opposition no doubt now at some point
there's going to be a confidence vote
David on the government's uh plans today
that they tabled but of course this is a
minority government so they will need at
least one other party to help pass those
measures what's been the reaction so far
from the opposition yeah and that party
is almost certainly the NDP remember the
NDP and liberals have this Supply and
confidence agreement in which the NDP
has promised it will support the
Liberals on any confidence matter right
through until the fall of 2025 that said
NDP leader jug me Singh says he wants
the government to go further and faster
on housing my concern is that this is
again the delay of the Liberals that
announc something that's not going to be
available for years down the road again
shows their lack of urgency to deal with
something that is so serious that people
are saying right now I can't find a
house right now I'm worried about losing
my home now the conservatives no
surprise do not like this statement one
bit opposition leader Pierre PV telling
the House of Commons that he continues
to blame the federal government's
spending for high inflation and high
interest rates with this 20
billion do of costly new spending this
update can be summed up very simply
price is up rent
up debt up taxes up times up Common
Sense conservatives will vote
non-confidence on this disgusting
stand and no surprise the block kqu as
well piling on it does not like this
particular statement but once again uh
look for the Liberals to look to the NDP
to see these measures through far David
aen and Ottawa thanks David housing
costs continue to put upward pressure on
inflation but there are other factors as
well the annual inflation rate slowed to
3.1% in October that's down from 3.8% in
September the biggest factor a drop in
gasoline prices a decline of 6.4% in
October mortgage interest costs rent and
food prices were the largest
contributors to inflation last month the
Bank of Canada tries to keep inflation
between 1 and and
3% the feds are aiming to build 101,000
rental homes that's really a drop in the
bucket though compared to the 5.8
million new homes Canada needs to build
this decade to restore affordability
that's according to the Canada mortgage
and housing Corporation as Eric senson
reports renters are paying a heavy
price for now s sidik is withholding his
rent payment it's being hiked by his
landlord from $1,200 to $1,600 a month a
33% increase he says is above government
guidelines people living here are all
workingclass people who are finding it
difficult to make our ends meet with our
earnings it's unaccept unacceptable
first and it is not possible for us to
pay there are no power like the power of
the people sadik isn't alone several
tenant groups in Toronto have conducted
rent strikes this year it's a sign of
the problem millions of Canadians are
facing skyrocketing rent increases the
federal government plan to make $15
billion in apartment construction loans
available to builders is a start it's a
positive step in terms of encouraging
some developers that may be sitting on
the sidelines that had projects sort of
raring to go and sort of had stall them
because of the higher interest rates
governments are getting the message
Toronto City Council has approved plans
to add 65,000 rent controlled homes by
2030 requiring $30 billion from all
levels of government I'm
remain hopeful that the different
components of the
65,000 units of
housing road map could be implemented
the challenge in Toronto and other big
cities is finding enough land on which
to build to bring the costs down the
problem is a lack of developable land
Ian Lee says governments must cut red
tape and consider urban sprawl which
they've resisted for years we have to
create a lot more housing by for example
expanding the boundaries of cities but
ottawa's loans for Builders will not
address the rental housing crisis
overnight it's a long-term solution
which is in the case of a crisis when
you need an immediate Urgent Response
this is not the right response SED sidik
doesn't disagree he's happy to see
governments committing to more housing
down the road but people who are
suffering at this point of time it's not
going to help us right it's going to
take time construction takes time
construction takes time and s's rent is
spiking now Eric senson Global News
Toronto coming up next America's
influence on the isra Israel Hamas
hostage deal that was just
[Music]
announced the potential Israel Hamas
deal to release hostages and pause
fighting has been brokered in large part
with help from the United States
President Joe Biden has exerted pressure
on both Israel and Hamas to come to an
agreement and tonight he got a thank you
from the Israeli Prime Minister who said
that Biden's involvement helped improve
the deal as Jackson prco reports if
successful this could set the stage for
future talks to end the
conflict we we're now very close very
close we could bring some of these asses
home very soon for weeks the Biden admin
Administration has teased a possible
deal yes from the beginning the US has
been at the center of negotiations to
release hostages President Joe Biden
spoke directly with the Amir of Kutter
who hosts the leadership of Hamas and
Biden has pressured Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu to make
humanitarian concessions some see it as
a Vindication of US policy public
support for Israel but a lot of private
pressuring uh for you know increased
humanitarian Aid greater pauses fewer
civilian casualties pressure on the
White House has also been immense with
Americans held captive and Biden's own
party increasingly angry about the
civilian toll in Gaza the Democratic
base right now is royally uh there's no
other way to describe it there is a a a
serious level of concern particularly
amongst young voters about the
president's position in supporting
Israel the successful release of
hostages and a brief ceasefire could be
proof of American power as peace broker
in the region there is quiet optimism a
hostage deal could also allow more
humanitarian support to trickle in
though the US insists the issues are
unrelated it has always been the
position of the United States that we do
not need a hostage deal there shouldn't
that to to get more Aid in even a brief
ceasefire and the partial release of
hostages will be seen as a win a sign
that both sides can be convinced to
prioritize civilian lives in the middle
of a bitter and deadly conflict Jackson
prco Global News
Washington check your change ahead how a
scheme to smuggle fake tunies in Canada
was
[Music]
busted in India 41 workers who have been
trapped in a collapsed tunnel for more
than a week have been seen on camera for
the first time video captured by a
camera sent down to the men shows them
standing in a confined space and
communicating with Rescuers the workers
have been stuck since the 4.5 km tunnel
caved in 10 days ago authorities haven't
said what caused the collapse but rescue
efforts have been slowed by snags and
drilling through the debris in the
Himalayan
terrain a Quebec man's facing charges
for allegedly importing more than 26,000
counterfeit tunies from China it's
believed to be the largest bust of its
kind in Canadian history and if he's
convicted he could spend up to 14 years
in prison charia isri reports on how a
border officer found the fakes on why
experts believe there could be Millions
more circulating in
Canada how close do you look at your
change the chances are not that close
and that's exactly what scamers are
banking on Mike Marshall is a
counterfeit coin expert if it's a $100
bill
everybody looks at it a $2 coin people
just don't look at them he does and
knows how to tell a real from a fake the
front right foot on them both are
different one has the split
toes a package shipped from China caught
the eye of a Canada Border Service
Agency officer last January according to
sworn affidavits when the cbsa officer
opened it up she discovered more than
12,000 fake tunies all stamped 2012 and
stuffed in plastic bags they were bought
for just 5 cents a piece and addressed
to a man named Jean franois Jen from
cell Quebec officers allege they
discovered another
14,58 counterfeit tunies on his property
in addition to the stockpile uncovered
at the airport more than 26,000 counter
coins in all with a street value of over
$53,000 that is the largest bust that
has been reported by Canadian
authorities according to the cbsa one of
the sellers was a company called kshan
long life gifts located in jangu China
they're marketed as replicas and sold to
buyers in North America through
e-commerce sites Canada Customs it's
it's very it's they're busy so they
can't inspect every single package that
comes in and that's an issue the Royal
Canadian Mint declined our request for
an interview but in a statement said
counterfeit tunies are rare and added
that Canada has some of the most secure
currency in the world hopefully they're
waking
up I doubt it just because they've got
bigger fish to fry he's urging the
public to give their change a double
take teria isri Global News News
[Music]
Ottawa get close next when the Rolling
Stones are coming back to
Canada one of the biggest rock bands
ever is going back on tour next year and
they're going to be stopping in Canada
along the
way the Rolling Stones Hackney diamonds
tour follows the band's first album of
original music in in 18 years the band's
only Canadian stop will be Vancouver on
July 5th they last performed in Canada
in
2019 and that's global national for this
Tuesday I'm far Naser tonight's your
Canada is the Mackenzie Meadows Golf
Course along the bo River in Calgary
thanks for watching Donna will'll be
back with you tomorrow until next time
take care of yourselves and take care of
each other good
night
[Music]
n